what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about Aaron's new Titan form its
potential powers and abilities and how
strong Eren will really be now that he
has attained this new form before I get
deeper into it though please be advised
that this video is not for anime only
fans all of this information will be
drawing on the latest developments in
the attack on Titan manga so if you are
not caught up to the manga you
definitely should catch up it is
absolutely insane right now but please
proceed with caution you have been
warned also if you enjoyed the attack on
Titan content on this channel you want
us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications the only way that you
really will be notified is if you go to
the trouble of hitting the notification
bell and then also making sure to check
off the option that says all
notifications so we know that aaron has
been able to use the attack Titan and
its powers for years
but we only recently learned the true
extent of the attack Titans powers and
abilities and it was only a few chapters
ago that we saw Aaron used to war hammer
Titans powers for the first time on top
of the attack Titan and the war hammer
Titan powers Eren also possesses the
founding Titan and in fact he has
possessed it from the very beginning
because it was passed on to him by his
father Grisha along with the attack
Titan however until now Aaron has been
unable to unlock the powers of the
founding Titan because he does not
possess royal blood the only time he was
able to use it before the most recent
manga twist was when he used it by
accident while fighting the smiling
Titan when Aaron came into direct
contact with the smiling Titan who has
royal blood because the smiling Titan
was of course Deena Fritz Eren
temporarily gained the ability to
control pure Titans and to get them to
attack Reiner and bertolt but under
normal circumstances Aaron's fawning
Titan power was just kind of there but
completely dormant until now so what do
we know about Aaron's past and current
powers and how strong is he right now
thanks to the attack Titan power and
also thanks to his own training and
experiment
under the guidance of hanji aaron has
the ability to regenerate and harden and
his attack Titan form is above average
in terms of strength and agility when
compared to most other titans and as we
learned recently Aaron's attack time
also gives him access to future memories
the attack Titan the Titan power that is
always looking forward to the future
allows its user to seek glimpses of
memories that its future holders are
going to have I can't overstate how
incredibly useful this is even though
the attack Titan user doesn't always see
these future memories very clearly even
vague glimpses of the future can prove
to be extremely useful but because Aaron
is the son of the previous attack Titan
user Grisha he is able to access the
attack Titans memories more clearly than
someone who is unrelated to the previous
user so knowing this Aaron from the
future was able to show specific
memories of the future to his father
Grisha as a result the Aaron from the
present is able to see the future by
accessing grisha's memories of those
future memories that future Aaron shared
with him yes it is a bit complicated but
the point is that present time Aaron has
pretty clear glimpses into the future
and he has a good idea about what is
going to happen next which of course
gives him a massive advantage over his
potential opponents aaron has also
demonstrated the ability to use the
Warhammer Titans powers this includes
the ability to create deadly weapons
large spikes and other objects by using
the war hammers unique hardening
abilities on top of that
Aaron can potentially use the Warhammer
Titans ability to hide his real body
inside a powerful crystal and the
ability to control the Titan from a
distance by using the Warhammer Titans
flesh cord thingy you might think that
using this cord would be pointless for
Aaron with how powerful he currently is
but you never know if Aaron's plan is to
pull a Lelouch from cold Geass become a
villain who is hated by the entire world
and then unite the world by compelling
them to work together to defeat him then
theoretically he could use the Warhammer
Titans cord to fake his own death he
could do this by allowing his Titan body
to be destroyed leading everyone to
believe that Aaron is
while he actually escapes the
destruction because he was controlling
the Titan from a distance I only bring
this up because in this scenario Aaron
could actually survive and still achieve
the goal of uniting the world against
him and making them think that they
succeeded in destroying him this is
relevant if and only if Aaron really
plans to pull a Lelouch although I am
definitely not sold on the idea that
this is actually his plan but since I
firmly believe that Lelouch also faked
his death so that he could go on to live
in peace with c2 I think that Aaron
could theoretically do something similar
with best girl Mikasa but now we have to
talk about the real key to understanding
how strong Aaron is right now and that
is his ability to unlock the true
potential of the founding Titan power in
the past this was impossible because as
we know only members of the royal Fritz
family had the ability to control the
founder however after Aaron succeeded in
getting through to the soul or
consciousness of aamir Fritz the
progenitor of the Titans and after Aaron
convinced her to stop obeying the orders
of the royal family and to team up with
him instead Aaron has seemingly been
able to achieve levels of power that no
one else has been able to achieve ever
since Ahmir herself held all nine Titan
powers inside her body we already know
that Aaron is now able to control the
millions of wall Titans any wasted no
time before initiating the rumbling we
also know that Aaron was able to
communicate telepathically with all LD
ins including the Ackerman's using the
founding titan power we also know that
he has been able to achieve a new Titan
form that is gigantic in size and
differs greatly from his previous Titan
form the wall Titans are about 50 meters
in height because this was the rough
size of the walls themselves but Aaron's
new Titan absolutely dwarfs these wall
Titans in size Aaron's new Titan is way
bigger than these colossal Titans and he
appears to be way bigger than even rod
rhesus Titan which makes Aaron new Titan
form absolutely gigantic and bigger than
anything we've seen before that size
alone will translate into insane
physical power if we assume that eren's
Titan will be able to move effectively
and that he won't be prevented from
moving by gravity it is safe to assume
that this Titan will be able to
aisle 8 entire cities in minutes we know
that Rodri says 120 meter Titan had
trouble moving and he could only crawl
he was too big to stand up straight
without support but it is safe to assume
that Aaron thought of this and it
appears that he has structured his new
Titan body to look like a dinosaur and
of course we know that the anatomy of
dinosaurs allowed them to grow to a much
larger size than humans that being said
the largest dinosaurs on record were
about 40 meters in length from what I've
been able to gather so even if we bring
the dinosaurs into it the current size
of Aaron's Titan form is incomparable it
is just so much more massive but
assuming that Aaron knows what he's
doing and assuming that this new Titan
form isn't just going to collapse under
its own weight it is also safe to assume
that Aaron's new Titan won't be very
fast in the past we've seen that the
bigger our Titan is the slower his
movements have been so it is possible
that the one big weakness of Aaron's
Titan form will be slow speed but then
the question is does Aaron speed even
matter if his Titan is so massive we
know that modern weapons technology has
been advancing rapidly and Marlay and
its allies are going to have artillery
capable of piercing through the armored
Titans Armour at their disposal but
rhinos armored Titan and Aaron's current
Giga Godzilla Titan are two completely
different things there is no comparison
not to mention that there are hundreds
of thousands if not millions of wall
Titans to think about sure the Marlin
army and its allies will be able to take
down some of them using modern weapons
but here's the thing how many weapons do
you need to destroy this many colossal
Titans
how many artillery shells would it take
to take down Aaron's Godzilla Titan at
this point I don't think that
conventional modern weapons will be able
to stop Aaron's attack there are just
too many Titans they are just too
massive and on top of that they can
freakin regenerate the Marlins will try
to shell them with artillery they will
take down some of the Titans probably by
blowing out their legs they might even
kill some of them by blowing off their
heads and damaging their napes
but I simply cannot imagine that the
conventional weapons that we've seen so
far stand a chance against Aaron
time even if we're talking about a
massive army with thousands of these
weapons at their disposal previously I
would have said that Marlin airships may
have an advantage over the wall Titans
because they can simply fly over them
and drop bombs on top of them but
judging from the panel in which we see
eren's Titan alongside the colossal
Titans this Godzilla Titan may actually
be as tall as 550 meters if not more
historically the type of airship that
the Marlins use had a normal cruising
altitude of about 200 meters in our own
world so in order to fly above eren's
Titan they would have to fly about three
times higher than they're used to this
means that any potential bombing would
be far less accurate and it also means
that the airships would have to deal
with much rougher weather conditions
than if they were flying three times
lower finally with the amount of sheer
mass that Aaron's Godzilla Titan appears
to have it is questionable whether any
bombs that are light enough to fit on an
airship can even do any significant
damage to such a colossal frame but if
that wasn't enough physical powers are
just one aspect of Aaron's potential
strength the telepathic powers of the
founding Titan are potentially even more
deadly
we know that the founding Titan could
communicate with aliens telepathically
it can erase the memories of aliens and
it can even change the physical
composition of aliens such as
potentially sterilizing all of them or
making all of them immune to a certain
disease we also know that the founding
Titan can create Titans on mass like
Carl Fritz did with the wall Titans now
we've never actually seen the founding
Titans straight up turn LD ends in two
titans without any injection or spinal
fluid ingestion but if we assume that
because the founding Titan can change
the physical compositions of all LD ants
even from far away it is possible that
Aaron can now spontaneously turn all the
ends on the continent into Titans and
use them for this attack as well I am
not 100% sure on this because we've
never seen it done but if it is possible
then every subject of aamir on the
continent is a potential Titan soldier
in waiting not to mention that even if
they don't turn into Titans the aliens
of the continent may choose to rebel
against the Marlins anyway once they see
what Eren can do this new shock
turn of events could give the LD ins on
the continent the confidence to finally
fight back oh and did I already talked
about the fact that Aaron can see the
future and plan accordingly calling
Aaron overpowered right now would be a
comical understatement
at this point Aaron could literally
stomp out all life in the entire world
except for Paradise Island then he could
erase the memories of all LD and so that
they don't even realize that there was
ever any life outside of paradise and
then we would come full circle in the
attack on Titan story the world was
destroyed by Titans and the last
remnants of humanity exists only on
Paradise Island Carl Fritz's fictional
story actually becomes true and no one
will even blame Aaron for destroying the
world because no one will remember that
he actually did it except for
potentially Myka son Levi if as members
of a minority bloodline they are still
immune to the memory manipulation in
conclusion I don't see any one being
capable of rivaling Aaron in any way at
this point be it another Titan shifter
the Marlin army or anyone else Aaron is
just that strong his one physical
weakness might be slow speed but if you
consider the fact that he can control
millions of Titans and do a bunch of
other insanely opie things
telepathically it's hard to imagine that
his slow speed would even make a
difference the only way that Aaron's
enemies might stand a chance against him
is if they secretly manage to develop
weapons of mass destruction such as
nukes if these ultra powerful weapons
have been secretly invented in the mean
time then maybe they can do enough
damage to actually slow down the wall
Titans and Aaron's Godzilla Titan but
without something as drastic as nukes
Aaron and his current Titan form is by
far the strongest entity in the entire
world and his power rivals the power of
the original
Ahmir Fritz Titan in fact because aamir
Fritz obediently served the Royal for
its family but Aaron serves no one and
he is free to do whatever he wants
Aaron may be able to unleash even more
of the founding times power than Emir
was able to do because she was always
concerned with following the orders of
others at this point I have to quickly
mention Norse mythology and the monster
called your moon Condor the name
Jormungandr means huge monster and it is
an absolutely colossal cease
serpent that is large enough to wrap
itself around the entire Earth and grasp
its own tail
during Ragnarok the apocalypse of Norse
mythology your moon ghandar releases its
own tail from its mouth and climbs up on
land spraying poison all over the earth
and destroying everything in sight
since Aaron has to cross an ocean it is
possible that he will turn his Titan
into some sort of sea serpent and with
all the Norse mythology references an
attack on Titan it wouldn't be too much
relieved to assume that Aaron's new
massive Titan form is a direct reference
to your moon gander eventually according
to Norse mythology the god of thunder
Thor will kill your moon gander but he
himself will also be killed as a result
of the monsters poison so make of that
what you will and of course let me know
what you guys think is there any way to
stop Aaron now or is he just so strong
that he is simply unstoppable personally
unless he himself secretly plans to be
defeated I don't see anything short of
nukes being able to even slow Aaron down
let alone defeat him but I could be
wrong so feel free to share your own
thoughts down in the comments below I
always love hearing from you and I love
when we get a good attack on Titan
conversation going if you enjoyed the
attack on Titan content right here on
this channel and you want us to keep it
going please leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest attack on
Titan news and updates I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who support us and make videos
like this one possible special thanks to
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh baby ray nothing
but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell dress
fitted ala beat Anatole Cassatt Sookie
DJ Nathaniel and alpha do and I can't
forget our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand above all other class
including Ingrid ah a Lola madam madam
AK makoto-kun and the world and you know
he's serious because he didn't say so
Waldo if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to your
life please consider becoming a patron
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]